Never have I ever thought
about having kids with you.
All of this is where
we're going. Um, Gosh.
I wish we had time.
Wayne living
and Amber Dylan.
And how long have you been
together? A year and a half. Yeah.
Breath.
Can I go first? No, I never have.
I ever pretended I was sleeping
so you wouldn't bother me.
Wait, how many times? I've
tried to think three. Ooh,
you've ever done that before?
One?
Of course. You really
surprised about that. Come on.
Hey, I'm tired. One for an
hour, I'm going to sleep.
Oh Wow. You're surprised
about that. I never knew that
I here. Thank you. Thank
you. Wait. Okay. Ready?
Never have I ever wished
that I had been raised
differently. Three, two,
one. Yeah, of course.
Yeah, always. But then, and then had we,
we wouldn't be here right now. Not Right.
But it definitely makes me think as a
child and looking back on your past and
have those moments, like what if, what if,
and I think most of us do, right? Yeah.
What if I had two parents?
What if my dad hadn't died?
And what if my mom hadn't been
cold and hard and unhappy?
What is my thought?
I had my father in my life.
What if my mother was in my life
and my grandparents didn't raise me?
What if I didn't choose this path?
And I chose that.
We were just talking to my
brother about that today.
So I'm happy for how your lifeline
so that we can be together.
Hmm.
Never have I ever done
something to fit in? Three, two,
one. Ah, we're not coming.
Not Right. Not Lately,
but for a long time. Yeah.
No. Well, listen, if I cared,
how about what other
people thought I was doing,
I wouldn't have gotten out
of my 35 year marriage.
Yeah. Just becoming more of an
individual, loving myself more,
allowed me to not want to fit into a role
or fit into this confines that society
puts us in. I mean, even just shaving
my hair and saying, screw you.
Beauty concepts. You know, like,
yeah, when I got all day,
I got rid of my braids.
I was free. Yeah. It's too,
uh, never have I ever wanted
to live in another country.
Three to one. Uh, that's right.
That's our movement of Bali
in a month. We're bouncing
to Bali. Yeah, of course.
It's time to get out of here and all over
the world could get two hour massages
with a good tip for $14 and so ready.
Let's go.
No,
never.
Have I ever lied to.
You knew this was going to be question
intentionally.
Is that like what it means or just push
the button and then we'll find out.
You have, I mean, we have, okay.
What I was thinking of just in terms
of, you know, what's going on? Nothing.
Uh,
yeah.
And then not telling you something.
I mean, I'm just thinking about,
you know, lying, cheating, stealing,
all the things that I've done in my life
and like how toxic it was and negative
and now it's just so clear and
not like that. I don't know.
I can say anything to you and do you
hear me? And you support me in it,
but I guess, yeah, fight for each
other. That's the answer. It's great.
Never have I ever said I love you
to someone without meaning it.
Three, two, one. Oh No.
Like nothing I've ever done it.
I don't think I, yeah, me either.
Like being in situations where
it's expected or you received it.
It's like a, I don't return that
stuff unless I feel it. Yeah.
You're like, I love everyone, so it's
fine. It's not real. Like, of course,
I won't even tell you I love you when
you're not in the mood when I don't feel
it. But you always love
me. I always loved it,
but I'm not always feeling like
I know. Right. I always live.
I'm like Whitney Houston over here.
Just be patient.
Oh yeah.
Well,
okay.
You
ever have I ever wondered how I would die?
Three two, one, two fad
on one on one after one on one time.
Okay. Yeah, of course. How are you today?
They've
hopefully in your arms.
Oh,
I don't know what some sad or give
me like just past together and it's a
beautiful way.
You got other why?
Because you got a lot more years after me.
I am a kid. Yeah. We can't do that.
Um,
I definitely would love for it to be
peaceful and surrounded by my friends and
family and like have a party.
Yeah.
Never have I ever been
disappointed in you.
Mm.
Oh, I can't be disappointed. I know. Yeah.
I mean I get frustrated and irritated
and annoyed and angry and intolerant and
upset with you,
but never disappointed.
Never have I ever felt unlovable.
Hello.
Oh, I did it again. Okay. Three, two.
Okay. Um, yeah,
there is the half of my life
I felt unlovable and then
I started to love myself.
No rarely these days because
you've showered me with
so much love and helped me
to love myself. You really have, I mean,
you've transformed me year
and a half unrecognizable.
My life is unrecognizable.
Never have I ever
correct.
Never have I ever thought
about having kids with you.
Oh,
this is where we're going.
Gosh, I wish we had time, but
maybe next week. Thanks for coming.
Thanks for playing.
Yeah.
I,
but not because necessarily I want to
birth a child in this world right now
because we could totally
birth and awesome being,
but I don't feel like the call for,
I think we're birthing projects
then I feel good about it also.
We really just can't do that.
Oh you mean,
well I have had a couple of kids. Um,
have I thought about having kids with you?
Yeah,
of course it happened.
[inaudible] there's so much time we don't
have to figure that out and there are
lots of children who, so many children
to be adopted. Sorry if it came to that.
I mean, you know, I love baby. I ain't
need no other babies and puppies.
Let's just adopt a lot of puppies in Bali.
Evolving weird barking
crazy dog and balding. Yeah.
And so ready to be on a scooter in the
rain at the U K I know this table we
said,
oh those are fun.
And I was never really nervous. I
felt really grounded in good. Yeah.
That's cause you're a professional.
Thank you. Like this. These,
these are sensitive questions
and like it just shows us,
shows me at least how much work we're
doing and how vulnerable and open and
honest we are. And so that just
feels really good. The work works.
It works if you work it right,
check,
oh,
you're still here. What
are you doing? Subscribe.
And if you haven't done that, go ahead
and check out the rest of our videos.
After you do that, you'll definitely
want to subscribe, but seriously,
get out of here. What are you
doing? What was I doing down there?
I don't know.